[Music]
Rebecca Joe kufran my Becca will you
marry me
[Music]
do you feel as though a weight has been
lifted off your shoulders oh yeah this a
little lighter today yeah on your feet
so much lighter I'm so nervous to say
his name in public though I'm a little
bit really ya know we don't need to use
code names anymore amazing what kind of
code names did you have he was Vincent
she was Veronica Vincent and Veronica
did you come up with those yourself yes
that Veronica was already kind of like
her alter ego and but the last name of
my phone was bushel peck and that came
from yeah I wrote a little note like god
I love you bushel and a peck it's about
time you got that name
I was supposed to make an appearance in
the last episode but he didn't what
happened there oh yeah it was a
conversation that we had and Denis was
fighter was just us pushing each other
the best and moving out of our lives but
was it supposed to air and then it
didn't air what would happen I mean
there's just so much that happens with
each week what I love is that it focused
on the relationships that were forming
on my journey so what's next what's next
he's gonna come to Minnesota for a while
and I have never been to Reno so I'm
gonna spend some time there and then I
think we la la may be south of LA a
little bit he likes some more of the
water
I think this traffic would be a lot to
handle so yeah we've to figure out where
exactly we want to land and do you feel
though that that might not give you the
privacy that maybe you need right now to
really get to know each other I think
we'll still be fine getting to know one
another we haven't put a time stamp on
anything you know we're kind of just
going with the flow and it's not like
we're set in a date or anything like
that so no date still said no Davis
you're saying okay we just want to walk
down the street holding hands yeah a
baby says yes
you